huh all right yeah I mean we got to
summarize
[Applause]
[Music]
so series 12 is over I'll have the
ranking video up later this week but
first let's do an overview on series 12
and I do want to do that separate from
the ranking because when I do the
ranking of the episodes that is looking
at them just relative to each other it's
not putting the series in context of
anything greater than itself so that's
why I do that separate so talking about
the series overall broad strokes this is
an improvement on series 11 almost
across the board
I felt like most of the individual
episodes were stronger I felt that they
managed to find an overall progression
that worked well I still don't love the
mystery box element and I really don't
love what was revealed at the end of
that mystery box but we'll kind of come
back to that
so the overall quality of this thing is
up quite a bit from series 11 like I
haven't done a re ranking of the series
since the end of series 10 was the last
time I did it and I don't know if I'm
gonna do a ranking of them overall yet I
don't know maybe I'm not anytime soon
but series 11 is down towards the bottom
like maybe the bottom I don't know but
it's down there it is rough series 12 is
a big step up like even both in terms of
batting average and in terms of how high
were the highs hello were the lows so
for me the low point of series 12 that
was worth in 55 that was really really
rough but you know what even that as
much as it didn't work didn't infuriate
me the way arachnids in the you
kay did so the worst episode of the
series 12 is not as bad as the worst
episode of series 11 not for me at any
rate whereas some of the high points I
would say definitely meet if not exceed
series 11 for me series of limit only
had two truly excellent episodes and
those were it takes you away and demons
of the Punjab and then like there were a
couple of that were good and then there
was a lot of meh and there's a lot more
good to great in this series I love can
you hear me
I liked Skyfall quite a bit the haunting
of villa did did it did whatever it was
that came out really well despite my
having big issues with one specific bit
going on with it that was still really
good ascension a Cyberman was a great
build-up as much as I didn't like the
reveal and the secret from the timeless
children that was still a really solid
finale episode and it's just got more
good going on here and even stuff that
for this series is more middling like
for me the Nikola Tesla episode or
praxis
they're still better than a lot of the
middle angst uh from series 11 so like
the whole bar feels like it has been
raised quite a bit and I'm I'm a little
bit annoyed to have to say this because
and I'm gonna say it in a specific way
the series in the series series 12
benefited from a series arc that is not
me reversing my stance on mystery boxes
I will continue to say that while the
show has benefited from a series arc
mystery boxes are not the only way to do
it find another trajectory
do a connecting story I'm just sick of
the format so sick of it so I'll
continue to make that complaint
regardless of what the mystery box is
uncovering but as much as I had thought
you know the show should be doing more
standalone stuff
part of what benefited series 12 was
having more of a sense of overall
trajectory and there were a number of
things that add to that bringing the
master back was a solid start because it
left you wondering uh when's that gonna
come back and then fugitive of the jeune
introducing Ruth and like what is going
on so much is so weird and then Jack and
the idea of the lone Cyberman and that
gets that kids name checked and then we
see the guy and he's awesome and he's
creepy and then essentially I was like
how ha it was a really good progression
and the interconnectedness and even as
far as a mystery box goes I did kind of
like that there were multiple elements
that were stringing us along that wasn't
just repeating the timeless child times
channel the timeless child oh here's
what the timeless child is which is the
format that these mystery boxes tend to
fall into there was a little bit more to
that when it was dropping things like
the master and Jack and the lone
Cybermen that were pulling us along
along the thread of the same story but
they were different things as opposed to
just repeating the same thing that we
don't have contacts for and don't know
what it is and I also liked that you
know Jack named name drops the lone
Cyberman and then it's only a few
episodes later that we see the thing so
it's not like he said it in Episode one
and then we finally see it in episode
ten no the the gap there were episodes
that effectively ultimately ended up
being filler episodes you know practice
Nikola Tesla or if I'm 55 but the the
filler just sort of gave us a little
breath between the introduction of an
idea and some degree of payoff furl
at first some of these things and that
that was pretty
structured overall season wise yeah but
okay so the timeless child the doctor is
the timeless child the times child is an
unknown being that is why V Time Lords
can regenerate which means that all of
Time Lord society is basically built on
the back of the doctor and whether the
doctor remembers that or not that makes
the doctor effectively a mech god figure
thing is though as much as I don't like
it it doesn't really impact this season
not really what it's going to impact
more than anything else is future series
and how this plays out and how it is
utilized and touched on and what it
results in so it's like it's like an
election year if the results of an
election aren't the one that you like
you may get really grumpy about the year
the election happened in like say 2020
the one that we're in now if the
election whatever your stance is
wherever you fall if the election
results are not the ones that you want
you may be like oh man 2020 sucks but
you know what news for you
the bad result of that all the things
that are going to result from the thing
you don't like those aren't gonna hit
you too the next year or the year after
or the year after so that's kind of how
I'm viewing the timeless child thing
right now I still don't like it and I am
gonna knock series 12 a little bit for
introducing the idea but ultimately I
can only knock it so much because it
really was only until the specifics of
it got revealed in the latter half of
the very last episode that I got
infuriated so I don't want to dock the
entire series cuz the build-up to it was
well done
the thing that it was building up to I
don't like I want to make the allowance
that maybe how this will pan out will be
done in a way that is far better than I
can imagine
I'm not going to blindly hope for that
and I'm sure as heck not going to assume
it's gonna be the case I need it to show
me that it can be that but I'm not gonna
rule out that possibility
I'm still thinking like I just I dislike
this idea so much to my core I'm I can't
help but be really nervous about
anything that comes out after this that
picks up after it but that was literally
like the last 30 minutes of you know 9
plus hours worth of television so I
can't knock the series too much for that
as angry as I got in that review and
while I've calmed down I'm not anymore
okay with that just to be clear but
overall series 12 I think was a big step
up it felt like a much surer hand Sears
11 felt like it was stripping things
down but didn't know what to rebuild
itself has this feels like it has a lot
more confidence behind it it had a lot
more sense of purpose behind it and not
just because there was an overarching
story although that is part of it it
felt like things were being done for a
reason for a character reason for a tone
and world reason for a thematic reason
whereas a lot of series 11 I can look at
a lot of those episodes ago I don't I
don't really know why you decided to do
that good or bad it's just kind of there
series 12 isn't just kind of their
series 12 is a lot bolder and a lot a
lot more creative and a lot less
middling a lot more daring
it's daring to go into an area that I'm
not sure I wanted well I know I don't
want the show to go too and I'm not sure
how well it can be done but there is
something to be said for going boldly in
a questionable direction versus sitting
around in the safe zone serious 12
didn't do the latter so I don't know how
happy I can say I am with the series
overall but I like the trajectory of if
not the narrative thanks to that twist
at least the quality of the show this
felt much better then series 11 did in
almost every area while I'm still trying
to wrap my head around this this doctor
in a lot of ways I feel like I'm
starting to get a hold of her yaz was
done much better things are things are
coming together and hopefully they'll
continue to do so even more in the next
series we'll see next year the weights
between these things man God those are
my overall thoughts on series 12 come on
back tomorrow
can I remember my own schedule something
like that for my ranking of the episodes
but in the meantime whatever your
thoughts are drop something on down in
the comments let's talk about a bunch
stuff to do like subscribe share this
around maybe check out my patreon or my
Amazon wishlist or I've got a peel box
if you want to send me stuff because it
is my birthday this month and I will be
opening up things on a live stream on
the 24th so you know maybe tune in for
that but for right now I'll leave it at
that and you don't have to do any of
that stuff cuz end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]